en fait j'étais en train de refaire ses
cours l'aider à faire ses cours de
mathématiques qui me semble un de
mémoire et là elle me dit
papa et j'ai eu un court il ya une
quinzaine de jours et je voulais en
parler j'ai oublié montre moi ton cours
est donc un montre les cours et le pôle
équipiers qui est là
et pour essayer de nuancer les choses
avec ma fille de lui apprendre des
choses sur la vie pas être toujours dans
temps la confrontation lui d'ibn nafis
ça c'est soit maladroit soit c'est
raciste
je lui explique ça pour pas qu'elle se
braque contre sa prof ou contre
l'éducation nationale où j'étais a droit
au départ ou bien c'est raté de ludique
c'est soit maladroit ou soit raciste
et je continue c'est d'avoir est bon on
va se coucher
il semble qu il est 21h je suis une
publication
à 21h30 soit vous décidez publié un
message sur votre facebook perso voilà
son facebook et vous dit voici le cours
de svt de ma fille si vous trouvez que
pas ceux-là raciste c'est que vous êtes
un gros fachos éducation nationale de
merde ne nous laissons pas faire et là
ça prend une ampleur actuelle même pas
pas si c'est non même pas c'est au mois
de décembre 2020 psa après on les six
personnes ou 7 à interagir sur des
commentaires et on a interagi
c'est quoi la réaction des gens sur les
réseaux d pas en fait on s'en prend
juste à l'éducation nationale et à aucun
moment on cite la professeure on sait
même pas que c'est la professeure de ma
fille ne pense même pas alors à
l'origine le film ne sait même pas que
c'est la professeur qui a fait ça de son
propre chef et
donc on réagit
on trouve que c'est raciste il y en a
qui trouvent que que non
oui comme et ont exigé un débat
là-dessus mais c'est super nanny jet lag
trouvé asile un abri
oui je l'entends il n'y a pas de souci
bien sûr et
je me couchais il ya une quarantaine de
commentaires et je me couche le matin je
valais pour aller bosser c'est toujours
choqué par cette crise au lendemain
matin comment vous êtes toujours chaud
où il pose une question oui
il faut un peu de recul et de réflexion
et là je ne dis
est ce que je suis le seul papa donc si
on parce qu'il y avait tellement que
c'est l'éducation nationale - est-ce que
je suis le seul papa en france avec tous
les cours des étés qui a et tous les
toutes les 3e et kia qui trouvent ça
raciste et là je me pose la question à
savoir l'origine de la chose et je
trouve qu'il est 8h45 j'ai déposé des
ouvriers sur un chantier
et j'appelle le proviseur qui est un ami
et un ami à vous le savez un ami il faut
le savoir et vous déplacer vous dit pas
c'est le boire voilà qui dans l'après
midi dit qu'il n'est pas dispo que
je vais souvent au collège pour d'autres
raisons que j'ai évoquées après est
hélas quand je lui montre j'arrive au
collège à 14h30 et quand je lui montre
ce que j'ai pris en capturer
sur le corps de ma fille il est un peu
abasourdi
et là quand je vois l'arrière qui sont
sa réaction celle de l'adjoint celle
d'un prof de maths je comprends tout de
suite c'est par l'éducation nationale
donc on s'explique et il me dit
m'expliquer là c'est du ressort de de la
prof des professions et là une demande
de sortir qu'ils allaient convoque donc
il voulait convoquer la
professeure de svt
et donc à ce moment là je suis dans la
dans la cour je crois que je fume une
cigarette
il ya la terre classe il ya ma fille qui
arrive et quand je sens que c'est là
donc j'ai se doute donc que c'est la
prod qui a fait ce polycopiés
geslin théorie ma fille qui passe avec
ses copines un flic est super charmant
de lembras et
et je leur posais une question je leur
dis elle est comment votre prof parce
que moi le soir quand j'en parle avec ma
fille pour nous c'est encore l'éducation
nationale ayant l'audit arrière le matin
là bas nommé sa prof d'accord voilà vous
demander comment ils leur prof est que
si vous répondez et je crois qu'il ya
quatre cinq copines avec elle on dit non
elle est cool super gentil ça se passe
bien il ya aucun problème
donc
à ce moment là je crois que je me ferais
rappelé par un surveillant parce que le
proviseur m'appelle ils me demandent de
m'installer
de m'installer je m'installe ndi la
professeure chose à vous dire
moi je vais je vous dis mais moi je
pensais que c'était l'éducation
nationale et par la professeure hélas la
prof à me dis que tu es monsieur dit mon
nom est dit
je suis désolée si ceci si cela vous a
choqué je voulais susciter l'intérêt des
enfants d'accord quand j'entends c'est
dire et le retour
des collégiennes donc et ma fille qui
dit qu'ils disent qu'elle est super ça
batteur il paraît que ça se passe très
bien vous dites je dis moi
vous savez madame quand vous n'avez pas
été et je pense que beaucoup de
personnes ici n'ont pas été quand vous
n'avez pas subi la discrimination ou le
racisme on peut pas se mettre à la place
de ces gens là
de mon passé oui j'en ai reçu et j'en ai
subi j'ai jamais été victime jeune
victime il réserve je serai jamais la
victime des personnes trans mois et là
je dis quand vous vous n'avez jamais
subi le racisme la discrimination vous
pouvez pas mettre à notre place alors et
je décide et je lui dis 'bon côté' -
madame je vais rentrer à la maison mais
je n'avais pas internet sur sur le coup
et je lui dis je vais enlever la
publication est pour moi l'affairé est
réglée paraît que vous paraît que vous
serrez la main ah ouais voilà sans vous
et s'est excusé mutuellement vous mettez
de supprimer la publication et dès que
vous entrez vous publier ce message
salem bonjour après avoir discuté avec
l'enseignant qu'il s'agit d'un
malentendu une grande maladresse de sa
charmante elle s'est platement excusé
j'aurais rejoint relate les faits et et
l'âge et les directeurs qui est un ami
je veux pas l'accabler après les
problèmes internes à l'éducation
l'éducation nationale ou à ce collège là
je sais pas de mon ressort et là il me
dit il est
impossible qu'on laisse passer ça vous
êtes venus on va envoyer ça à l'académie
svt et moi je réponds au directeur dudit
mélange pour moi c'est l'affairé close
on ne doit pas aller plus loin c'est
peut-être une maladresse voilà et jean
marais plage egée après avec insistante
où elle est mal défendu dans les
commentaires voilà avec l'assistance du
directeur jeudi écouter bon je peux pas
m'immiscer dans les problèmes de du
collège voilà ce qui se passe avec cette
professeure et donc ce proviseur en fait
c'est au viseur il a été très choqué par
la frise chronologique wind besser il
faut pas en rester là et ils vous disent
qu'ils décident de faire donc comme on
m'a dit tu es remonter la sphère
l'académie de versailles qui est en
charge du collège de vos enfants c'est
ça ensuite en jouer en juin 2021
d'officiers de la police judiciaire vous
appelle vous convoque au commissariat
pour rester en garde à vue quand même
temps en fait ça se passe pas comme ça
il m'appelle lundi à 15 heures je suis
sur un chantier il me dit monsieur
g je veux vous entendre 'conserver'
concernant une affaire tu poses c'est
quoi il me dit non tout est venu au
commissariat et je vous explique judy
j'arrive donc si tu es mon chantier jeu
par contre là j'ai un petit
une petite réflexion donc je me permets
je le rappelle et je lui dis donc à ce
spectacle est inspecteur très très
gentil je lui dis
est ce qu'il ya une garde à vue à
l'issue est il dit en ces termes
monsieur il serait préférable que vous
veniez demain matin
donc je pense qu'il a voulu éviter que
je fasse une garde à vue
j'arrive le matin le dit le mardi matin
il ya des choses qui sont choquantes
j'arrive le mardi matin je me présente
chantant du
lait dire que ma déposition corrobore
avec celle du proviseur celle de
son adjointe celle du prof de maths il
sample et des personnes qui ont été
entendues
et là on me redescendre dans la garde à
vue et
il me rappelle à 15 heures on dit
monsieur je pensais qu'il allait me
donner ma dire de sortir quoi il dit non
par contre là j'ai deux questions à vous
poser qui m'ont été demandée par le
procureur
et
la première question c'est est-ce que
vous avez créé une association
judy oui et j'ai aidé des gens j'ai fait
des choses avec voilà
s'associant sion qui pousse les gens à
aller voter à la halle entraide à la
citoyenneté c'est elle et c'était notre
démarche il me pose une deuxième
question tout aussi troublante est-ce
que vous avez créé un parti politique
donc en 2019 à
19 me sens je lui dit j'ai une carte de
séjour c'est ma réponse est ce qu'avec
une paire de séjour on peut créer un
parti politique ou même être allés voter
in dinars lui dit c'est ma réponse et
après on and off entre nous et là je lui
dis
je lui dis la vérité je dis oui j'ai
créé
un parti politique parce que je voulais
c'est ça hein avec une carte de séjour
vous parliez juste avant de l'insulter
française
avec un ami qui s'appelle arnold sylvie
- mais dont on s'est décidé de créer un
parti politique c'était citoyen en
actions d'accor et
judy entre parenthèses on l'a fait quand
même 6 % pour des clous voilà moi de
nous on tourne on s'appelait les coups
nous on a quand même fait 6% et je lui
dis bon oui je les fais donc je lui
avoue avoir fait mais en off et là on
dit
monsieur si ça ne tenait qu'à moi je
vous convoque pas n'y a pas d'affaires
d'accor au pire au pire je vous entends
sur l'audition libre et pas sous le
régime de la garde à vue
il m'a dit j'ai une telle pression une
telle pression qu'il a reçus pour choix
dans ses locaux le mardi matin qu'ils
devaient aller interpeller un violeur
dans la commune voisine qui s'appelle
but en cours
qu'il a été obligé de remettre à jeudi
dont on est mardi d'accord et moi c'est
ça qui m'a choqué
tout ce qui s'est passé les policiers
vont même jusqu'à vous faire questionner
pour air et votre téléphone à la fin de
votre garde à vue les policiers vous
donne une première date de jugement donc
une première le 10 mais voilà c'était
s'était finalement repoussée au 15
novembre c'est à 2021 voilà c'était 18
août à la barre c'est ça et après case
2021 vous décidez de ne pas prendre
d'avocat oui à temps vous en avez un
très bien et le procureur avait demandé
huit mois de prison ferme 10 mille euros
d'amendé cinq ans d'inégibilité et vous
êtes finalement condamné à six mois de
prison ferme dix mille euros d'amendé et
cinq ans d'inéligibilité
par cette peine dissuasive le tribunal
veut éviter de nouveaux drames c'est ce
qu'il honnit du type de type samuel
pâtit le procureur en plus est en charge
de la sphère pâtit c'était le même
procureur s'il faut savoir donc ça c'est
un élément important
donc aujourd'hui vous êtes condamné donc
à 5 ans d'éligibilité or n'est pas la
nationalité française ce que vous avez
dit il ya un instant